est-ce que vous pensez que vous êtes une
rock star vault moi je suis un musicien
bon le fait d'avoir été dans téléphone
et comme tout a bien marché je deviens
guitar hero pas on va voir on va faire
un rock star alors est-ce que vous avez
par exemple déjà saccagé la chambre du
palace dans lequel vous étiez descendu
n'ont jamais vraiment il m'est arrivé de
menacer il m'est arrivé de menacer de
jeter la télé par la fenêtre parce qu'il
y avait des coups de marteau au dessus
et que j'ai un besoin de dormir quand
même ouais est ce que j'ai déjà choisi
comme ça dans le public le soir la fille
que vous allez ramené après oui oui ça
c'est bien ou mal
le groupe n'en a jamais non est-ce que
vous avez déjà eu des problèmes
judiciaires à cause de la drogue
non je vous ai déjà essayé d acheter une
boîte de nuit et un restaurant
comme tout les pop stars alors je
pourrai pas gérer un truc bar-tabac
comment ce petit mais rien du tout même
une buvette je saurai pas gérer est ce
que quand vous venez quelque part comme
ça vous imposer des trucs particulier
dans votre loge à l'époque de téléphone
quand c'était très gros je demande à une
table de ping pong à backstage ça va
encore empirer reinhardt d'accord mais
on était des rockers assez tranquille
ouais est ce que par exemple ou boxer où
vous avez boxer des paparazzi jamais
jamais été emmerdé par les papas bape
nouba paradis est ce que vous avez eu à
ça c'est un truc de vraiment de rockstar
des filles qui disent que vous avez mise
enceinte non sur une table de ping pong
jamais je crois pas non jamais roma
n'ont jamais eu ce genre de problème
est ce qu'il faisait déjà failli mourir
d'une overdose dans les toilettes d'une
boîte de nuit autour est-ce que les gens
n'osent pas vous contredire quand vous
dites une énorme comme je dis jamais ton
louis bertignac de sa belle longtemps
c'est son troisième album solo et ça
sort en ce moment
en tournée en france du 13 au 15 avril
non on va partir du 16 mars
oui en france et du 12 au 15 avril à
l'européen à paris trompe aussi des fois
ça m'arrive aussi fait bien ça c'est toi
mais si je ne vois pas ce que tu m'as le
mieux piquer c'est quand je me trompe
ben oui c'est vrai c'est ce que tu me
dis et je le perfectionne seul prisme et
mines